my family has been living here for more
than 70 years
crack started appearing in a house in
2021 they started getting bigger we
thought it was routine we covered them
with cement on around 3rd January they
became very big during monsoons we were
very scared when it rained heavily we
would leave the house the water was
coming from all sides and we were scared
the walls would collapse you can see we
have stuffed clothes into those cracks
since around November 2021 we've been
asking authorities to take a look at
these cracks a local official came last
year and rubbished our concerns we even
gave a memorandum to the Chief Minister
when he visited a nearby Village but
nobody listened to us now that big
hotels have developed cracks the
government is finally waking up on
January 6 they asked us to shift there
were few houses here a lot of tourists
come to early to key people want to earn
more so many buildings have come up
people started selling their Farms there
are lots of buyers a lot of people here
are Outsiders
it's very difficult to live in the
hotels we only go there to sleep our
cows are here and other stuff we bought
with much difficulties here where will
we take it the hotel is only for us but
where will we take the cows they are a
livelihood the government is saying
they'll give us 1800 but we haven't
received it we'll go to the government
office when we get time but what will we
do with eighteen hundred dollars our
staff costs more than three thousand
dollars we took a loan to build a house
we want full compensation for our land
and our house that's when we will shift
from here where will we go after leaving
our land